I'm Desiree help me help help I'm just
seeing a night April fast because I
don't think that this is focused
correctly I need to fix the focus okay
um can you go get the boom mics that we
don't have okay cool
I think that looks good do you think
that looks okay yeah okay all right
sweet what are we talking our network to
network to TV yeah is that we're talking
about today all right cool
no more I am oneness oatmeal no what's
network-to-network to is the guide to
the best video content on the Internet
separated into categories viewers can
then mix and match their content to
produce their own channels to publicize
on the Internet
how do you watch internet TV how do you
watch it network to dot TV see if you
can find something about a sandwich okay
here we go
sandwich search that is a lot of hits
Desiree I'm sorry